well i'm joined now by the shadow
leveling up secretary lisa nandy uh
newton andy what do you make of of this
idea do you it is a good idea is it not
to encourage people to own their own
homes in principle it's a great idea to
try to get more people the security of
their own home particularly people who
find themselves in the benefit system
the problem is that as always the
government hasn't thought through the
detail there's no sign that any of the
lenders are on board with this the
government can say that it wants to open
up mortgages to people on housing
benefit but unless the lenders agree to
do it it's not going to happen there are
real practical problems as well if
you're to qualify for universal credit
you've got to have savings of less than
16 000 which mean that most people who
the government are trying to reach with
this announcement are not going to have
anything near the amount that they need
for a deposit on a home in order to
qualify for that mortgage the government
does have form on this they've done it
before they said a few years ago that
you wouldn't need
a building fire safety certificate on
your home in order to qualify for a
mortgage if your home was below 18
meters the mortgage lender said well we
still demand one and it made absolutely
zero difference so great idea but
absolutely unworkable in practice
because the government hasn't as usual
done the legwork and thought through the
details so what would labour's
alternative be because we do have a
problem with people struggling with home
ownership in the uk i mean there are
things that you can do immediately you
could speed up um measures to um crack
down on unfair leasehold charges that's
something we're proposing today ahead of
the housing debate that michael gove and
i will be having later today in
parliament we should be taking more
action to increase the supply of
affordable homes in the end that is the
only way to really solve the housing
crisis for most people the measures that
the government announced today
won't begin to do that for most people
and in fact some of them will make the
housing supply crisis even worse one of
the things that michael gove has done
that is positive is make some funding
available to bring brownfield sites back
into use that would open up land to
enable properties to be built but the
government has been far too slow at
getting that money out
and enabling it to be used so that we
get those homes built they're the sort
of measures that the government ought to
be focusing on if they really want to
solve the housing crisis for most people
in a broader sense about leveling up but
other than northern ireland london is
the only economy in the uk which uh it's
a scene increases below pre-pandemic
levels what would labour be doing to
ensure more leveling up there we've got
to get we've got to get good jobs back
into parts of the country that have seen
them bleed out of our communities for
the last 40 years there is no substitute
for it the government is handing out
small pots of money which yesterday a
select committee of mps issued a very
damning report about saying that the
government had squandered billions and
billions of pounds of our money on these
small pots of cash that are being doled
out around the country that we have to
compete for hunger games style in order
to to try and spruce up our high streets
the reason high streets are struggling
the reason town centres are struggling
is because people haven't got money in
their pockets there are short-term
measures that the government could take
to deal with that we've called for an
emergency budget and a spike in the
national insurance hike to try and help
people right now but long term they've
got to get investment back into other
regions of the uk in order to get those
good jobs back it's why these measures
that they've taken in the last few weeks
around um
carving the bus subsidies um about
cancelling northern powerhouse rail
about scrapping parts of the high-speed
two-link that would have helped to
alleviate congestion on our rail lines
in the north of england these are so
short-sighted because it harms private
sector investment and it harms economic
growth
but also things that could be seen to
harm that are rail strikes which are
coming up at the end of the month and
and you've got people who are now
finally going back to work in the office
after a couple of years of living with
covid you've got people who are really
struggling to make ends meet
how do you think they're gonna fare when
when they can't get into work at the end
of june because the railings are already
talking about striking uh
you know without even really sensibly
talking about it well i hope they will
be able to get into work because if the
government were to be proactive about
this and bring the rail workers and the
rail bosses together i'm confident that
we could find a solution in the end the
solution for the public is not to run
down the people who work on our railways
who kept that service going during the
pandemic who turn up for work day in day
out to help people get around i know
from my own experience you know my dad
is in his 80s traveling on the railways
he couldn't do it without the support of
those people who work really hard for
very low wages but to make it happen but
so do many of those using the training
well that's right you depend upon those
traits they too are working really
that's absolutely right they deserve a
good rail service and that means that
the government has to
avoid these strikes by sitting down with
rail bosses and rail workers and
reaching an agreement not just attacking
the people who run our railways over and
over again as they have done for a
decade it hasn't worked it hasn't helped
it's had a devastating effect not just
on our rail workers but on the
passengers as well who use those rail
services and we deserve better than that
but when you talk to a lot of passengers
they're furious about this they they
don't feel a great deal of sympathy
especially in the southeast you know
we've had all the the big rounds about
whether whether or not guards should be
on trains
and passengers don't necessarily many of
them feel that that it's a justified
reason to be going out on strike well
we've had that row about keeping the
guard on the train up and down the
country and people feel very strongly
that they want to see the guard on the
train if you're a woman traveling late
at night if you're an older person
someone with disabilities the guard is
incredibly important for you and you
know greater manchester we had a
terrorist incident we don't want to see
those people who are responsible for our
safety and security on drains
removed
or attacked by the government we want to
see the government treat our rail
workforce properly come to a sensible
agreement to make sure that those people
and their families can eat and keep
their heads above water and stay afloat
and keep our rail services going this is
perfectly possible it can be done but it
takes good will and it takes a
government that is proactive and is
focused on the things that matter not
squabbling amongst themselves on the
cost of living of course we're talking
about fuel as well this morning the
price is going up potentially over 100
pounds for for a family car we spoke to
michael gove a short while ago he said
that that the government's going to be
keeping a close eye especially on
supermarkets uh what would labour be
doing to try to get these fuel prices
down well i think i think this is the
biggest issue in relation to fuel is
that we had a 5 p fuel duty cut and much
of that doesn't appear to have been
passed on by the retailers to consumers
if i were in government right now we
would be coming down like a ton of
bricks on those retailers particularly
those who are sitting on that money
not passing it on to customers because
they're waiting to see what happens with
petrol prices in future they don't want
to raise prices again and so they're
sitting on that money just waiting to
see what happens that's just not good
enough when people are really struggling
as far as i know the business secretary
has only written once to those retailers
to ask them to pass the field duty price
on i'm not sure if any of them even
bothered to respond the government
the government ought to be calling them
in and saying to them there is a crisis
affecting people in this country right
now and that fuel duty cut must be
passed on to customers and they ought to
be bringing forward an emergency budget
i suspect that they probably will now we
told them they needed to bring in a
winful tax to get money into people's
pockets and off their energy bills and
they finally accepted that they would
today the prime minister's team are
briefing that he's going to say in the
coming weeks there will be some action
to tackle the rising cost of living we
would say to them spike that rise in
national insurance contributions as your
first priority we are the only major
economy in the world to be putting up
taxes on working people in the middle of
an inflation crisis it's just not good
enough it has to be scrapped okay also
this week the other big political story
of course boris johnson fighting for his
political career that was the big vote
on monday let's just remind our viewers
about what michael gove said about this
a moment ago
how did you vote for him this week did
you did you give him your your support
on monday enthusiastically yes uh i
think that it's because you've not
always been an enthusiastic friend or
supporter have you no i i made a mistake
in 2016. um uh uh a misjudgment um if
you've been in politics for a little
while as i have been then um you know
there are always mistakes that you can
look back on but no i think the prime
minister is doing a good job so you
wouldn't run against him as a potential
new leader oh god no
he wouldn't run against boris johnson
but what about kierstarma there's been
quite a lot of criticism of yesterday's
uh prime minister's questions the fact
that he didn't really attack the prime
minister at all about what had happened
over the week that he's not really
holding the prime minister's feet to the
fire
we're talking about a conservative
leadership contest but should there be a
labour one no absolutely not the kirsten
yesterday was talking about the issues
that matter to people in the country the
prime minister is doing a good enough
job of sabotaging himself and his own
reputation and that round will continue
to run within the conservative party
that is a tragedy for the country when
we need a government focused on the
issues that matter to most people the
rising cost of living the growing
waiting list for cancer treatment these
are things that keep families awake at
night and care is absolutely right to
use our platform as the official
opposition to raise those issues with
government and to set out plans that we
would take to tackle them in the hope
that the government will take them up
now but if they won't we will fight for
those at the next general election and
put them into practice as the next
labour government okay lisa nandi thanks
very much for coming in this morning